so we got like a bundle this is
something everybody probably knows about
but if you guys want me to tell you I
will so like through our insurance
provider we have our car insurance our
home insurance our life insurance and
then like protection on what's in our
house all under an umbrella like
insurance policy which makes it way
cheaper so if you go through one company
for all those things you can get massive
discounts health insurance is the
toughest and that's not something that
like I have a good solution for because
like I said we don't have control over
it so if you're lower income you
probably qualify for Medicaid wherever
you are in the United States I think the
UK has something similar right for
low-income people there's like state
government healthare it may not be the
best but it's something um if your
husband has a good job he may get good
insurance through his work